[Music]
it took just seconds for the confusion
to turn to panic and then
terror families fleeing as a lone gunman
opened fire from a roof
[Applause]
[Music]
dozens were hit by the bullets pram
buggies and other belongings abandoned
as the lucky ones ran for safety
there was a young child there that
people i was doing a little cpr until
the paramedics got there and he looked
horribly injured i'm not sure exactly
the injury but i mean people were doing
anything they could it was it's a mass
casualty scene i remember seeing
people's faces they were kind of
confused
because they didn't know if it was like
you know part of the show or whatnot
like
it was just crazy and i just heard i
just remember hearing people screaming
and running
a police manhunt is now underway
the suspect is currently described as a
male white
approximately 18 to 20 years old
with longer black hair a small build and
wearing a white or blue t-shirt
a firearm has been recovered from the
scene
we have secured the perimeter around
downtown downtown highland park and are
continuing our searches at this time two
dozen people have been transported to
highland park hospital
six are confirmed deceased
a rifle has been recovered but it's not
clear whether the gunman has access to
other weapons
president biden has said he is shocked
by the senseless attack and he's not
going to give up fighting what he calls
the epidemic of gun violence
this person is not yet in custody we
have hundreds of police officers out
here as the mayor said from the fbi the
state police other federal agencies we
have swat teams that are going door to
door as well
a number of children were among those
admitted to hospital with gunshot wounds
of the 26 individuals that showed up
here at highland park hospital 25 of
those did sustain gunshot wound injuries
some of them were minor some of them
were much more severe and some of those
patients were in critical condition when
they did arrive here to the hospital
many independence day events in illinois
have now been cancelled
for the residents of highland park july
the 4th will forever be remembered as
the day a violent attack tore lives and
the community apart joe pike sky news